die ganze nacht sitzen
[Musik]
der große tag ist gekommen ich kann
überhaupt nicht einschätzen aber wer
eine nacht voller regen voller
feuchtigkeit und kälte hinter uns sind
aber eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert
ich bin happy schlaf bekommen und jetzt
gilt es irgendwie auf die gletscher zu
kommen ich habe schlaf bekommen anders
als bei tine und jonas vom blue horizon
aus dem hier deutlich härter gemacht
hatten als ich das video aus ihrer sicht
ist gerade online gegangen check das aus
lasst lieber da und er findet den link
zum video in der video beschreibung und
damit auch herzlich willkommen zu teil
zwei des gletscher videos ob wir es
geschafft haben was alles passiert ist
und was ich zu den kommentaren sage die
untere teil 1 zu finden waren
erfahrt ihr in diesem video
[Musik]
in europa hin ihr seht schon das wetter
ist aufgeklärt geht weiter tag nummer
zwei
damit der entscheidende finale tag heute
geht's hoffentlich auf den gletscher
[Musik]
der erste abschnitt hier sind absoluter
traum genau so hatte ich mir das
bergsteigen vorgestellt haben ein paar
flüsse bachläufe hier überall so
gemischte vegetation bisschen steine
bisschen wiese und wir kommen dem gipfel
immer näher
oder zumindest unsere zwischenetappe das
macht wirklich richtig laune und wir
wollen jetzt erst mal wasser hier in so
einer frischen quelle auf damit wir
hierbleiben altera vorbei man muss das
hier komplett mit allen sinnen das meine
ich 100 prozent ernst wahrnehmen bringt
mich zur musik laufen zu lassen das
bringt nicht zu viel miteinander zu
lagern ist ein absoluter traum und aus
dem nichts auf einmal ein riesiger see
wahrscheinlich habt ihr euch auch schon
gefragt wie wir uns auf dieser tour
versorgen wir sind jetzt kurz davor ganz
oben auf den gipfel zu steigen und wir
brauchen beste versorgung deswegen
vielen vielen dank an drei food den
sponsor dieses videos in einer flasche
sind 500 milliliter drin und alle
wichtigen vitamine und nährstoffe die er
so über den tag braucht ich kenne das
selber ich benutze es zuhause ich
benutze sie jetzt auf solchen reisen
wenn ich die komplette fritz weineck
experience haben will mich auf sein
neues welt vorbereiten will dann brauche
ich dafür natürlich auch fritz meine
kiss hauptsponsor mutig danke vielmals
dass die minis projekte unterstützen mit
dem coach dave 10 über den ersten link
in der video beschreibung könnt ihr das
große paket testen da sind alle sorten
drin fürs auf die special edition zu
vielen vielen dank dass sie mich an
dieses projekt er unterstützen check des
außen absoluter traum mich immer an
diese tollen bilder die lauter
fotografen machen wo man das gebirge im
see so was kann ich
[Musik]
anstrengender als jedoch einmal so
richtig wo und wie haben wir das erste
mal gemerkt was es wirklich heißt auf
eis oder schnee zu laufen und wie lange
man da wirklich braucht also ich war
davon ausgegangen dass es eigentlich so
eine standard gute ist die super krass
ausgelaufen ist wo wir anderen leuten
begegnen und so aber es wird nicht der
fall
wir haben keine einzige person gesehen
[Musik]
ich glaube die erste etappe ist
geschafft haben wir hatten uns extra
ausgesucht als etappenziel für tag zwei
nach dem ersten vier stunden damit wir
einfach mal zur ruhe kommen können und
so ein bisschen aufwärmen können
na ja da ist komplett also komplett
spiegelglatt ist die hütte geöffnet
schwierig ein alter aber guckt euch das
mal an jetzt sieht man das erstmal das
hier wirklich einfach verschenkt spalten
drin sind und ich glaube da geht halt
wirklich einfach bergab
und hier will ich ganz kurz ein haken
und auf kommentare von teil 1 angehen
kommentare die häufig gekommen sind und
kommentare die absolut richtig war
ich hab mich dafür entschieden so eine
tour ohne erfahrungen zu machen und das
auf youtube hochzuladen und das war dumm
im endeffekt habe ich gemerkt dass ich
mir über viele sachen nicht richtig
gedanken gemacht hat wer rettet mich wer
bringt sein eigenes leben in gefahr um
mich irgendwo runterzuholen nur wenn ich
mich nicht richtig informiert habe weil
ich mich übernommen hat weil ich eine
grenzerfahrung haben wollte absolut dumm
noch viel dümmer das ganze zu teilen das
ganze so dastehen zu lassen als wäre
alles super fan and games und das würde
ich nicht noch mal machen ich mich dazu
entschlossen in zukunft erst mal wieder
ein bisschen abstand zu nehmen weil ich
merke dass ich alles was ich anpacke
sehr extrem mache und da meine eigenen
grenzen einfach nicht kenne und da
vielleicht auch nicht das richtige
vorbild bin um solche sachen zu machen
wenn ich etwas mache dann gerne mit
professionellen leuten die mich dabei
unterstützen die mir die gefahren
aufzeigen können die mich auch retten
können bei gefahren oder die nicht
einfach anleiten es tut mir leid und das
wird nicht mehr vorkommen völlig
verrückt was wir im letzten tag
geschafft haben wann dann checkt das gar
nicht so richtig weil man das die ganze
zeit um sich herum sieht aber wenn wir
da vorne weil jonas so laufen sehen wir
befinden uns einfach auf über 3000
metern
und so ging es auch weiter mit voller
ausrüstung bestehend aus pickel
klettergurt und seil schafft zu laufen
und steigeisen was quasi spikes für die
wanderschuhe sind ging es los auf das
letzte stück erzählt los
aber jetzt geht's richtig los dann
erklärte gut dran während die steigeisen
haben das pickel und dort oben
richtig schwierig es wird noch mal
richtig
jetzt geht's ab dem berg um zehn nach 1
und das muss bis 16 uhr durch sein ist
viel anstrengender als gedacht
der gipfel zu diesem zeitpunkt schon
wirklich in sichtweite aber immer noch
weit entfernt wie weit entfernt und wie
anstrengend das letzte stück sein würde
kommt mich zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
überhaupt nicht einschätzen
schritt für schritt
der weg ist noch so lang so wenig zeit
schmidt
für schritt die jungs keine
pessimistische habe eine realistische
einschätzung
ich weiß wirklich nicht ob ich das
schaffe ich weiß wirklich nicht ob ich
mich nicht hier mit komplett übernommen
ich bin so an einer grenze und ja wir
kommen voran wir machen meter
ja es ist so also ganz im ernst jetzt
können weiterlaufen und wir können
checken wie weit wir kommen aber sicher
fühle ich mich nicht ich merke durch
einen kopfschuss
sie wird das war ein herz pumpt dass ich
keinen atem habe aus der reihe kann
dafür
geradeaus gehen kann ja ich würde auch
noch ein bisschen weiter versuchen aber
ich merke auf jeden fall jeder schritt
ist sofort na ja und mein kampf
überhaupt nicht einschätzen
das hier ist zum greifen noch viel mehr
mit
dass sie keinen meter das ist richtig
böse
nachdem man sich einen kompletten tag so
krass gequält hat will man einfach nicht
mehr umdrehen man hat sich selber zu
viel angetan man habe zu viel scheiße
fressen als dass man auf dem letzten
stück dann umdrehen würde obwohl es
vielleicht sicherer oder schlauer werden
ich kann nicht reden
geht übrigens auf den kopf die holt auf
die lunge natürlich auch auf die beine
aber nach zwei tagen absoluter top tour
gedanken die einen schon auf halbem weg
mehrmals hätten umdrehen lassen einer
nacht im zelt während stufen und
gewitter auf über 3.000 metern und
schmerzenden beinen füßen und köpfen
haben wir das geschafft was niemand von
uns für möglichkeiten hätte ach du
scheiße alter
das video haben wir wirklich erleben was
meine sicherheit angeht und auch was die
sicherheit meiner zuschauern geht macht
so was nicht und auch ich werde davon
erstmal ein bisschen abstand nehmen und
wir jetzt noch mal ganz kurz es hat
trotzdem übels bock gemacht also es war
übels dom ist gefährlich aber es war
unendlich geil
es war unendlich krass so oft über seine
grenzen zu gehen genau dasselbe wie beim
fahrrad fahndungs hat mega rock gemacht
aber es lohnt sich nicht dieses risiko
einzugehen für ein bisschen spaß genau
dieselbe anstrengung hätte man auch
gehabt weil man mit einem bergführer
gegangen wäre so haben wir einfach nur
unnötiges risiko gehabt ich hoffe
trotzdem dass wir die gefallen wenn ja
was man gerne leichter vergesst nicht
den kanal zu abonnieren damit der
kanzler folgenden videos verpasst lasst
es euch gut gehen